- My mom is my best friend, Linda,
and she's completely selfless.
She volunteers thousands
of hours in her community,
and she was diagnosed with
terminal breast cancer
and given two years and
that was four years ago.
So, she's still with us.
She's raised us kids, and I promised her
that when she beats it we're
gonna take her to see Reba,
and that is a goal of ours.
But she's really sick,
so having you sing it
is the next best thing
because we absolutely love you.
So thank you so much.
- Did you say she was given
two years and its been four?
- [Blonde Woman] Yes
- She's one hell of a fighter.
- Yes, she absolutely is.
- That's a beautiful thing,
four years and they gave her two.
She got this.
- We had a couple close
calls but she's been good.
- Come on up here.
Come on up here.
(applause)
- Thank you so much.
I love that, thank you.
- I was expecting a fun thing
and that's not a fun thing.
I'm so sorry.
- She's fine, she's fine.
- I know she's fine, but
that's a heavy thing.
Well tell me little bit
more about your mom though.
Why is she such a big Reba fan?
- She's always raised us on country music,
and growing up in the car, at home
she's always played Reba for us.
So we've just always
grown up with the music,
and she's huge on country
so I'm huge on country
Huge on Kelly.
- Yeah
- Yeah, you singing it
was really big for her.
- Okay, well I love your mom.
- She's awesome.
- So what's your mom like?
Is she fun like you?
- Oh, she's tons of fun.
I could tell you stories,
but it's probably not
appropriate for here.
But we've gone to Vegas
- Oh my gosh, I love her.
- for her 50th,
and we have get togethers at the house
and she host all the
holidays and all the parties,
and she's amazing.
- Oh, she' a light.
- She's so much fun.
Even though she's sick,
she makes sure that she's
the life of the party
as best as she can be
and she still does
everything for everybody else
even though she's going through
what she's going through.
Everybody else comes first.
- That's a beautiful mom.
All right, well I am honored you said
I'm the next best thing to Reba,
but I think your mom deserves the best
so please welcome country
legend, Reba McEntire.